obviously it helps to be an animal lover
when you start working at a shelter it's
not exactly a requirement of the job but
it definitely makes it a little more
palatable when you occasionally have to
deal with a critter that's more nasty
than usual having an already built in
compassion towards animals makes it
easier to forgive them for not doing
what you want from a very young age
harper always liked to think of animals
as people they just didn't think or
communicate the same way as humans even
the best trained pets in the world don't
really know the actual meaning of
certain words they're just taught how to
respond to specific commands in certain
ways but that doesn't mean they couldn't
also have distinct personalities of
their own just like humans do and then
of course there were all the wild
animals that had never been trained or
domesticated harper always felt a little
sorry for any baby bird with its wing
broken or any badgers or possum that
arrived at the shelter after getting hit
by a car they didn't live around humans
and had probably never even experienced
being indoors before let alone having
people nursing them back to health to
empathize harper used to imagine how
terrified she would be if she was hurt
if she'd broken her leg or arm or worse
only for something much larger than her
to take her into a structure she'd never
been in before and on top of that having
no way of understanding that this giant
was trying to help her heal as well as
being separated from her friends family
and everyone she knew the way she saw it
this was what it must have been like for
the majority of animals that were
brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patients you gotta fortify your heart in
this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold and heartless
that would be an over-correction but it
was their and harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate medical care
and provide a temporary sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
what harper had to remember was that
none of them were her own pets often a
lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone
else's companion and might have just got
lost while out on a walk and while some
others were given up by their previous
owners who had cruelly shrugged off the
responsibility of caring for them those
animals were in need of new homes and
couldn't stay cooped up in the shelter
forever not everyone that gave up their
pet did it callously though sometimes
they might have found themselves falling
on hard times and being unable to
financially look after an animal others
might have owned a pet that had a
behavioral problem like being too
aggressive and even though the person
still loved them dearly they might have
just not been able to make it work in
times like that they'd have no choice
but to take their animal to the shelter
just outside the side entrance was an
area where people could drop off their
animals and quickly buzz to the staff
inside just in case they wanted to avoid
a protracted emotional farewell to their
four-legged or winged companion the
buzzer had sounded just as harper had
been coming off her lunch break it was
her turn this shift to quickly go and
collect any animal that had been left
out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cage or with
their lead tied to a nearby street lamp
harper knew she had to rush to the side
door just in case somebody else tried to
rush in and steal the poor abandoned pet
after turning them in the lock she
hooked her keys back on the belt clip
she wore and pushed the side door open
harper had been fully expecting to see
the usual a leash dog or cat coming over
to investigate her confused as to where
their former owner had gone this time
though there was just a box standing
outside it wasn't huge in fact it was
almost entirely empty almost picking it
up carefully in case there were baby
birds or a nest of unhatched eggs inside
harper opened the cardboard flap to
reveal a rock sitting in the box was a
single solitary rock an oval of smooth
granite with a paper note next to it
reaching in she retrieved and unfolded
the scrap please care for my pet rock
was written on one side in a messy
uncoordinated scroll immediately
assuming that this whole thing was some
kid's idea of a joke harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabies and
a squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave she
headed through the side door mainly so
that she could do a final check in case
any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and harper
hooked her bag over her shoulder
shutting the door behind her something
the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot causing her to
look down and see the rock the same one
from earlier only now it had flipped
over probably after she had tipped it
out of its box on the side facing up at
her the rock had a shiny metal zipper
fastened shut curious harper picked it
up to take a closer look it didn't seem
like the zip had just been glued onto
the stone's surface it was embedded in
it actually part of the rock itself and
there was something
sad about it sure it was just a rock an
inanimate lump of stone but for whatever
reason a feeling of pity crept up on
harper causing her to slip the rock into
her bag as she headed for the parking
lot it was starting to get dark by the
time she got home heading up to her room
and flipping on her lamp harper placed
the zipped up stone under its light and
took another long look at it although
she'd first thought it was purely a joke
now she couldn't tell if it was some
elaborate art piece or a quirky garden
ornament the thing was solid stone all
the way through surely the zipper was
just for show there couldn't possibly be
anything beneath it to her surprise the
metal fastener began to part as harper
dragged on the puller and slider down
from the top stop towards the bottom one
it was relatively easy not even some of
her own clothes unzipped as smoothly as
this rock as soon as the slider
connected with the bottom stop the teeth
of the top and bottom edges parted
revealing more teeth below except these
almost looked like human teeth they
opened up to reveal a mouth a part of
the rock just like the zipper which took
the place of its lips the moment the
mouth opened let out a tiny sound like
it was breathing which startled harper
with a yelp she dropped the rock from
her hands and it even made a tiny grunt
as it fell to the floor it was alive
seeing it hit her bedroom carpet harper
stared utterly bewildered at the rock
its toothy mouth almost looked sad like
it had curved into a frown then she
heard the sound it was making perhaps it
was her years working with animals at
the shelter and her long held sympathy
for them that had given her a sort of
protective instinct for all living
things or maybe it was just the
bizarreness of the situation of having a
rock with a mouth whimpering in pain on
the floor in front of her either way
harper felt compelled to pick the lump
of stone back up and place it gently on
the desk its mouth seemed to smile a bit
more as she did while it seemed creepy
at first the compulsion to take care of
this helpless little rock only got
stronger grabbing a pipette and pouring
a glass of water from the faucet harper
started to squeeze out droplets of water
into the rock's mouth she had no idea
how it was able to drink but that didn't
seem at all important or relevant in
order for her to care for it after all
every time a parrot or duck or crow was
brought into the station the procedure
was similar harper would have to pipet
them water or medicine it didn't matter
how they drank it just because they had
beaks it was the same with baby animals
puppies and kittens especially who might
need bottle feeding if they were only a
few weeks old as much as she was
starting from scratch and would normally
be completely baffled as to the best
ways she could care for the rock right
now harper was pulling on her experience
at the shelter to nurse it back to
health if she was in fact using her
instincts and not being influenced
somehow over the next few days harper
looked after her newfound patient as if
it had been her lifelong pet as to why
she was taking such care of a rock or
even what she would eventually do with
it harper didn't really have much of a
clue but the answer to those questions
didn't feel as important as looking
after the rock she'd leave for work in
the morning only to count down the hours
through her shift until she got to go
home and tend to the smiling stone
throughout the course of her working day
she would pocket supplies to help her
take better care of her new pet
everything from medicine in case it got
sick or picked up an infection of some
kind two bandages and other materials
she could use as bedding grabbing a
fresh clean plastic container for it
instead of another cardboard box harper
was gradually fashioning a nest for the
toothy pebble and for the most part it
seemed to be working some deep-seated
feeling told her that her efforts to
look after the rock was gradually making
it feel better every day and then it
started talking it wasn't exactly
articulate or eloquent it didn't even
seem to know that many words other than
the two it was weakly repeating when she
came home from work one day
it rasped a horse whisper passing
through its unzipped lips rushing over
to it barely questioning it harper tried
filling up her pipet and giving it more
water the rock spat it back out before
speaking again
now
drink only eight
what what do i need to feed you she
asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice or
could her compelling need to care for it
make her oblivious to the strangeness of
this situation of course this wasn't a
situation that many people had also
found themselves in this meant that even
a quick cursory internet search for what
do pet rocks eat didn't yield many
useful results only a few joke articles
and nothing that actually gave harper an
answer she could act on all the while
her rock was still croaking out the same
two words repeating them on a loop its
little voice getting more and more
forceful each time
eat eat eat low on options harper left
some bread crusts in the rock's nest
hoping that would be enough to at least
satiate the rock's obvious hunger it
paused either smelling or sensing that
it had been offered something to eat
it wraps before opening its mouth wide
with a tiny expectant
picking up the crusts one by one harper
broke little pieces off and fed each bit
to a rock she sighed as a sense of
overwhelming relief came flooding over
her glad that she'd found a way to feed
the mouthy little mineral if only it had
worked for longer only a few hours later
harper was met with more scraping
demands from her pet rock the insistent
sound waking her up in the middle of the
night but this time as she offered it
more bread scraps it refused to eat them
it was still the early hours of the
morning by the time that harper had
gotten through offering the rock every
different type of food in her kitchen
eventually giving up through sheer
exhaustion she folded her pillow over
her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of need
but it didn't do enough to allow her to
get to sleep at any rate the feeling
that she had to care for this talking
rock was keeping her awake as much as
the noise staring across the room
purposely facing away from her pet rock
harper's eyes fell over her work uniform
the logo of the animal shelter stitched
on it was just about visible as the
gentle glow of street lamps bled through
the curtains and seeing it along with
her keys clipped onto her belt that lay
on the floor gave her an idea that might
work
desperation and the need to sleep
getting the better of her harper climbed
in the car having put a jacket and jeans
over her pajamas the streets were all
empty at this hour almost pitch dark and
deathly silent but it made driving from
her home to her workplace a lot faster
than usual all the while the rock's
voice was getting more and more
demanding from its container that she
had strapped to the front passenger seat
sneaking up to the side door harper
turned her key in the lock pulled it
open and slipped in doors the moment
they heard the sound of the door
shutting a number of the dogs that had
been resting securely in their cages
woke up and started barking the noise
loudly echoing around the shelter even
though it drowned out the rock's tiny
voice it felt as if its words were still
ringing in harper's ears compelling her
to go through with something she really
didn't want to and yet it felt like one
of the only other options she had left
she decided it would have to be the
squirrel rationalizing the choice in her
head in an unpleasant but purely
calculated logic-based way it made the
most sense earlier that week the
bushy-tailed woodland forager had been
hit by a moped it had barely survived
given the number of its tiny bones that
had been broken in the force of the
impact finding its cage it was still
asleep heavily sedated on the dosage of
painkillers the shelter's resident vet
had given it gently scooping it out of
the cage feeling its fur against her
cupped hand harper looked at her pet
rock its container on the table she
remembered that it liked to be fed
directly swallowing an urge to be sick
that was rising at the back of her
throat harper opened a drawer in the
vet's office and pulled out a surgical
scalpel when her boss at the shelter
heard there had been a break-in and
reviewed the footage on the building's
security cameras they were shocked at
what they saw though the angle obscured
what harper was doing the blood left
over and one missing squirrel seemed to
be enough to go on that coupled with the
fact that she had broken in after hours
and the numerous supplies that had gone
missing from the storage cupboard led to
harper being dismissed she was fired
from her job at the animal shelter
forced to hand over her keys in uniform
while any other day this would have
devastated her the events seemed to wash
over harper pretty quickly she was more
relieved no pleased with herself that
the rock had stopped begging her to be
fed her plan had worked for now it took
about a week for her pet rock to start
demanding food again this time just the
sound of its voice made harper frantic
any ordinary human food she offered
wasn't enough it didn't want that she
already knew exactly what it wanted the
only thing she'd fed it that had
sustained it the big problem was that
now she didn't have her keys it would be
near impossible for her to get into the
shelter again yet still the forceful
command to be fed kept up day and night
hour after hour until harper considered
the only thing she had left to give her
pet rock lifting it out of the warm nest
she kept it in her fingers were gripping
the smooth stone tightly her arm was
tense in fact both were one of her
muscles strained while she held the rock
the other in anticipation hovering it
above her opposite arm harper could feel
the tiny breaths of her pet against her
skin almost like it was so excited to
eat again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quickly running into the bathroom
it wasn't that she had changed her mind
she couldn't all she knew was that she
had to feed her pet rock harper just
needed to grab a cloth to put it in her
mouth clamping her jaws down on it to
muffle her scream as she let the rock's
teeth sink into her flesh blood
trickling down her arm nobody saw much
of harper afterwards her friends from
the shelter would continuously call her
cell phone only to get no reply
she barely paid any attention to the
ringing eventually just letting her
phone batteries die and not even
bothering to charge it back up it wasn't
important to her the only thing that
mattered was caring for her pet rock in
harper's head it needed to be kept safe
and fed and it was her job to look after
it to the best of her ability she had
enough leftover medical supplies that
she'd lifted from the shelter bandages
antiseptic spray rubbing alcohol
tranquilizers to treat her wounds after
a while it almost stopped hurting
knowing that she was helping keep her
pet rock fed being so emotionally
attached to it made all the pain more
bearable even when she woke up one
morning to find that her rock had rolled
off her desk onto her bed it hardly
fazed her nor did seeing that it had
gradually eaten her leg during the night
gnawing through tendons and bone as she
slept leaving her sheets still slick
with blood when she awoke despite having
lost most of her capacity for rational
thought harper decided it would be best
to plan ahead for when she was gone she
knew through some twisted form of logic
that she wasn't going to last forever
there was only so much of her she'd be
able to feed her pet rock for so long
harper held a pen in her hand as best
she could with all the fingers she was
now missing she scrawled out a note to
whoever found what was left of her in
messy uncoordinated handwriting please
care for my pet rock if keeping an scp
as a pet is an idea that appeals to you
but you want one that doesn't come with
the added danger of eating you alive
then why not go and check out
scp-529 josie the half-cat or if you
really aren't a cat person or a half-cat
person but still want to adopt your own
anomaly then we might just have the
perfect list of candidates in top 14
friendliest scps